dallas is in missouri hey dallas what's
up
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
okay um so my husband and i have been
married it'll be five years in june
and we are debt-free except our house
good and i'm
wondering would it be wise um to take
out
loans to start a family
um so confused why that takes
are you adopted uh hopefully ivf
oh okay okay expensive all right
um yeah uh well i get this question
about ivf and about adopting
all the time uh both and i
i gotta tell you i can't think of
anything more
important than having children for those
of us that want to have children
it's been the greatest the greatest joy
of my life
except for grandchildren and uh
if i don't know how great grandkids are
going to be i'd have been nicer to their
parents but
um but the uh you know
in other words i i think the question
you're asking is extremely
important um uh but here's the thing
as you know there are no 100
procedures with ivf right
and um and a hundred percent of the time
you're going to have those payments
right right and so what's your household
income
um this past year it was about
52 000 but it should go up this coming
year because i've taken a higher paying
job
okay all right if i woke up in your
shoes is how i answer questions here
i would be willing to do almost anything
to make to make these attempts
okay uh but i would have to pay cash for
them
because i i i have a really really close
friend
who has um had three attempts and
one uh four four attempts one was
successful three were not
and the successful ended in a
miscarriage an early early early
miscarriage
and so it's been a lot of uh
emotional roller coaster for them
uh as you might imagine if you add to
that
the stress of debt right you're
multiplying your
your um you multiply the
the the stress in the situation
exponentially so
i want you to do this but i if it was me
and i woke up in your shoes i'd be
if i was your husband might be
delivering pizzas to pay for it or i'd
be
doing well i mean i'd take an extra job
you know because
and get the 7 000 the twelve thousand
whatever you're gonna whichever plans
you're
doing you know uh right you're not gonna
do that you're not gonna do the 25
thousand dollars
you're not gonna no it's not thirty no
that's not true
there's one plan this third about
insurance no it's without insurance
you know it's not 30 30 is a unlimited
attempts
possibly or something like that that's
the cadillac
gold package or whatever but uh you need
to you need to investigate what your
options are on how you can go about this
uh
you know it might be less expensive if
you had multiple things on a 30 but it's
no it's the guy i'm talking about is not
spinning yeah
and i i think dallas too you and your
husband sitting down and really talking
about
how important is this for each of you
and then what are you willing to
sacrifice to do this
i've been willing to sacrifice almost
anything yeah and and taking on extra
jobs
uh but committing to to really saving up
the cash to be able to do this
uh one of the people that i remember
coaching years ago
uh paid for three rounds of it uh it did
not work
uh and they were reminded
of the being unsuccessful every time
they had to make a payment yeah that's
what i mean
and they were constantly remarkable
and so it's just a thing i i would like
dave said be willing to do just about
anything but taking that on
uh and i wish you all well as you move
forward doing your research
uh make sure you're talking to a couple
of doctors and you're getting the
adequate stuff
but more importantly make sure you and
your husband are together and you guys
are in lock step on this
yeah but again i would cut lifestyle to
nothing i would work like a crazy person
five jobs
uh and then then if it works it's paid
for
and it's greater joy if it doesn't work
it's paid for and it's less sorrowful
that's right
but when you add the financial burden to
it it in either case it diminishes the
joy
or increases the sorrow yeah and that
that's the problem
so i'm with you though we're praying for
you and we we want you to have
have as many babies as you want to have
i hope it all works out